this saturday is your opportunity to put
smiles on children's faces who are in
hospitals across the country the annual
turkey trot takes place this saturday
november 20th 8 a.m at the orange theory
fitness west flamingo location here to
talk more about that is my good buddy
jeff civilico how you doing bud you look
ridiculous
look at yourself i do feel a little out
of place
how you doing how you doing man i'm good
good yeah it feels good this is uh how
many years you've been doing this now
this is uh
so we're not gonna talk about this this
is just us on a thursday afternoon we're
not even gonna we're not even getting
into it all right this is just us this
is the second annual this is a meme for
years to come right here
and you know what i actually wore this
last year but i've been wearing it for
365 days just to train because i want to
you know get the aerodynamics
oh the humanity sorry okay yeah anyway
i'm uh i'm thinking this year i'm gonna
be a little faster a little bit yeah
more aerodynamic exactly you are slimmer
or fitter turkey this year okay yeah
easy
will you call me no no no no no no not
at all it's fine listen this is a big
deal um by the way
you do look you do look fantastic
i have a lighter tone you've been
tanning i guess apparently i don't know
look at this
oh no look how dirty my feet
here's the final the full body shots
those are dirty yeah you did run in
those last years look this is so sad get
a shot of those hold me up
help me out okay so here's the thing
i'll just i'll just stand like this the
whole time to really improve this image
what people missed was you just you
literally ran through the front door
about a minute and a half ago so we're
like off to the side here and and three
people are helping us throw on these
ridiculous outfits this turkey is stuck
in traffic right right but we did it we
did it and uh there you are from last
year doing your things right doing my
life we try not to talk about you being
a juggler just because there's no
respectability in that i know it's it's
i know it's just above mine
below magician clearly way way below
okay so this if people want to
participate and by the way let's tell
people briefly what it's all about
people participate now we're sure that
they won't yeah after this
tell us what it's like okay so saturday
morning 8 a.m we're doing a 5k or one
mile walk so you can trot the 5k or you
can just walk the one mile if you want
suggested donation 20
all the proceeds go to win-win
entertainment which which i founded
current chairman and you are on the
board yes sir
why else would you agree to do this and
what's beautiful about this organization
is you have entertainers your
entertainer friends
right professionals like yourself yes uh
go into hospitals and now it's a virtual
thing yes because of the bring smiles to
kids all over hospitals nationwide we
have 17 hospital programs
well i'm just holding this up for you
okay
so sad
yes and uh
jeff whatever i'm over it ken
the show is canceled after this this is
it this is our last show ever we need
you we need your support the community
really this is a big fundraiser for us
it was very popular last year this year
it's going to be even bigger even better
we have more people registered already
we have more vendors signed up more
raffle prizes we have a live dj pink box
supply and doughnuts we've got coffee
we're giving out lulu lemongrass so to
register they go where win win
entertainment.org excellent and you
don't have to wear one of these
ridiculous outfits you can keep your
dignity and help kids uh let's take a
look at where you can get the stuff
where you have one more thing i was just
just saying but it's highly encouraged
but yeah you don't have to